[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
damn welcome back to the break room Our
Daily Show that keeps you updated on all
the nerdy news you need to know this
week of the break room is brought to you
by Pluto TV more on them later coming up
Charlie Cox dishes on Daredevil
we're still watching Andor and you
should too right Tommy absolutely I mean
sorry the host uh the Warner Brothers is
maybe getting their [ __ ] together
maybe possibly it really knows and oh by
the way on Friday of this week we're
doing hot ones so join us for that I'm
reading it for the first time in this
prompter surprise Jessica I can't wait
for our costumes for Friday you guys
that's right yes with me today keep you
surprised with me today is Brandon
Barrick oh hello hello glad to be here
Mike is not live oh that's not a real
mic hello
oh testing um Jessica who cares the host
to my right hi everyone uh hey do me a
huge favor like this video And subscribe
to our Channel don't make us wait till
the end and if you're not well if you're
watching this video sending in your
stupid chats that we don't care about
about how trashy you are and how your
ear rip your headphones and I'm a little
baby whose parents ever taught me how to
listen to audio properly and all those
chats the least you could do is like it
okay that's right I don't even want you
watching the happiest day of my life
would be if that chat is idle and
doesn't oh my God because you know what
I know finally the crash collectors did
their job took the trash out oh I got to
the right of the host is baby boy to
Prince Zach
uh happy to be here I like that though
besides all the awful stuff you said
there Tommy I like that as a general
sentiment there's like 1500 concurrent
people watching this why don't we have
1500 likes yeah why not let's do that
who's hate watching and if you're doing
that it's what is it three o'clock where
you are watch your soap opera or
something maybe you're only watching
then you like to hate watch right you're
in that Hellraiser pain planet from Rick
and Morty God is good good is bad uh and
also for our Super Chat redemptions for
every 100 in super chats we
we we have an inside person yes
Discovery now Warner Bros Discovery okay
uh several members of the janitorial
staff we know some security guards eye
level execs I've got a kissing contest
with one of the security guards so they
had what I said it's true let me tell
you Bryce I miss those lips We snuck
into the DC offices
we got some songs that are featured are
gonna be featured or were going to be
featured in the end credits for some DC
films that have been canceled and I got
to say I've I've just gotten a little
taste of these songs yeah they're
bangers you guys want to hear these yeah
okay unless you're a Sim and then you
don't want to hear a lot of times on
this show we've done songs are they
jokes are they real we don't know okay
these are real songs every hundred
dollars in super chats we erase these
are real songs we're gonna peel off a
real end credit song from a canceled DC
yeah uh I don't want to give away a hint
but there might be something from the
flash it's just not canceled oh okay uh
there might be something from Black
Canary which is unfortunately
girl getting us hot
um well speaking of Warner Brothers
Discovery DC all of that we've got a lot
of news from that Universe coming out
today or recently so most of what we're
going to talk about is that uh And
Timely because this is Black Adam week
that's right I'm coming out at the end
of this week we're all excited for it
it's coming out on Friday uh there's
been a lot of press about it and as part
of that coverage Hollywood Reporter uh
released a new profile on everything
that's happening around DC and there is
a lot of juice in there that's right uh
that lemon was ready to be squeezed
um so there was some really good stuff
in there about James Gunn yeah uh you
know I'm a big James Gunn fan and uh
speaking of lemons when life hands you
uh lemons you know or when life hands
you a bat girl you make a Black Adam
right oh my God
that's what you do I hear the hierarchy
of the dceu is about to be shifting my
friends so James gone you know my road
dog ride or die put putting putting the
first person to put a wrestler to the
Forefront of a DCU project Peacemaker
yeah he's got he's got some plans guys
after he finishes up season two of
Peacemaker which is happening which is
not being canceled I believe which is
shooting soon perhaps I'm not sure uh it
seems like he's gonna start he's angling
for his own project or possibly even two
now we think that James would probably
pull some more obscure characters out of
the old you know I mean he made
Peacemaker yeah uh a household name uh
do you think there's a mainstream
character that that he could tackle that
would be really interesting and is it
someone I mean he seems to do really
well with flawed individuals with hearts
of gold I'm yeah what's more
what's more main wait you want a main
street I was like what's more mainstream
than Harley Quinn you know oh well I
guess I mean like I'm talking like a
like a Justice League member perhaps
like like a hero well just thinking and
like we know like
Batman is dibbed already Matt Reeves has
divs on Batman well I actually hear
there's someone else angling for their
own Batman film but we'll hear more
about that okay very oh what a nice
tease Tommy
um Tommy Tucci's over here uh but two
keys and also we're gonna
uh I'm gonna let that uh slip by
undetected by most people uh also we
know Superman there's some news on that
we're gonna get back to we know Aquaman
Flash Wonder Woman they all kind of have
ongoing things it's like who's left well
one of the big cancellations that's
happened recently is that planned uh
Green Lantern series oh yeah wouldn't
that be fun we know James likes to go to
space with a Green Lantern Corps a kind
of his own DC Guardians maybe they're a
little wacky the game there's a lot of
wacky core members yeah yeah are they
still is that Amanda Waller series still
happening well that's kind of assumed by
Peacemaker season too I thought that he
had the on clarified spin-off or
Peacemaker spin-off or also HBO Max show
right so I'm wondering if these are all
kind of amalgamations of the same story
that are just have not yet to be sorted
out sure now we also know unfortunately
speaking of canceled properties this is
a little less uh of a mainstream
character but still a great character
there's a tana show that was in
development from old JJ Abrams has been
lens flared out of this galaxy uh and
she ain't coming back now I uh and a
friend of mine had an idea for his
Italian show years ago and if you're
listening uh James where she would be a
kind of like uh an aging Las Vegas
magician you know just like if she has
like a whole crew of Vegas magician
friends that are all you know they're
basically all Hustlers but she actually
has abilities and she kind of fakes uh
that that it's that she's also just an
Illusionist but is actually using her
powers to like uh get stuff done and
make money so I mean James Gunn kind of
doing like a uh
uh hacks type show or something like
that
a lot of Comedy I I like that and also
we don't know right like yeah there's
been lots of things rumored and these
all could be one sentences on a sheet of
paper or things that just got brought up
in a meeting right uh also HBO like
famously like with the Game of Thrones
sequels and spin-offs they greenlit like
eight to have scripts read even made a
pilot for one starring Naomi Watts it
they're like nope and they ended up
making house the dragon they might be
doing they might or they had been doing
maybe similar stuff with some of these
DC projects where they got 15 in
development knowing they're only going
to make a couple of them yeah that's
right yeah uh somebody and it looks bad
for the Mr mixoplick's porn parody
impossibly that ain't mixing Mr sexual
dicks oh my gosh what
Philip Beckham in the chat suggesting
and I love this idea that James gonna do
a series about the question that like
blank face oh yeah yeah that was like a
like a kind of Noir style right set in
the superhero Universe I think that that
would be well uh put a pin in that
because we're about to come back to some
similars all right let's do it so many
pains in the headlines a lot of pins
everybody all we're saying is this is
one of those episodes of the break room
where you guys stay tuned and you got to
pay attention because the clues are
everywhere do you have Mr policeman I
gave you all the clues
[Laughter]
horses potatoes in the chat well so um
speaking of of uh the question right uh
we know one thing that is definitely
happening is
um well and sorry another thing that was
canceled was a planned Constantine
series yes that's right but it's kind of
just been shifted we know this is part
of the zazlov uh you know can't sing a
bad girl and like restructuring a lot of
stuff or under Discovery they're trying
to shift less HBO Max stuff more
theatrical stuff so that was going to be
on HBO Max series now it's going to be a
straight up movie starring our boy Keanu
Reeves coming back uh illegitimate
family member of Matt Reeves director of
right the Batman they're not related
um but so we know Matt Reeves is doing
all his Batman stuff yeah oh you know
what I just realized I'm so sorry the
right porn parody is Mr pixel the dicks
so it's like pixelated like Asian porn
uh
keep it going thank God we're gonna uh
there'll be at least four more
reiterations Tommy's Gonna Keep
ruminating on that idea yeah
[Laughter]
throw in the chat your favorite uh DC
porn parody title oh boy oh sorry mezzo
sorry Fred girl sorry Chrissy
Memphis League there it is the spleen
Lantern it is
um like dick night would not work right
as a parody of Dark Knight
um because he's got dick right there
Grendel woman I think like the dick not
Rises Works wait why doesn't dick night
work but dig not Rises for some reason
he thinks you can have dick in the title
of your your show because it won't be TV
now now something like [ __ ] begins
DC
I mean I'm sure they wrote a Nutty
Professor crochet at some point
okay people clicked on this thumbnail
person isn't making music
but man already the name of uh listen
honey I want to show you my favorite
show the extreme live every day from
their break room it's really fun
you're a DC fan out there who's been
starved for good news oh finally finally
talking DC Tommy's [ __ ]
hey I like how you can draw that one up
but when I ask you for a nice picture of
me oh it's unavailable producer johnsy
canceled
um all right uh but so Matt Reeves is
out there he's still making a um the sex
men
oh that is a good one um but again we're
trying to keep it in the DC Universe the
sex Men Days of Couture is a blast
I'm done
X-Men worst ass
ETS
you know these are the more like Nitty
Gritty ones you gotta find
a DVD or
ders oh these are the trauma parodies
okay oh my God and no that was not
mandatory fun uh that's still yet to
come excellent dark penis
dark Phoenix we got it yeah okay
here's a comic okay
um okay so Matt Reed is out there we
know the Batman 2 with Robert Pattinson
is in development right they're working
on that we know a um Jeffrey Wright
Commissioner Gordon uh Focus series it's
also going to heavily feature uh the
penguin yes or is it it was just one
series now I believe so at one point
this is always so confusing there's
penguin there was Gotham PD there was
maybe like an Arkham Asylum show yes I
think it's just one show now and maybe
they work Penguins maybe they're always
the same thing but I think it's now
being referred to as a Penguin series I
believe
um but supposedly he's also working on
um a series of movies focused on
Batman's Rogues Gallery uh you know both
some of the established uh villains in
the Batman Universe and some more
obscure ones with characters ranging
from like scarecrow and Clayface who
fans the animated series are well
acquainted with to like kind of a more
recent comic uh villain Professor Pig
and that's what I was talking when you
were talking about the question right
Professor pig is a more recent comics
Australian who's like a serial killer
who wears a pig mask which is extremely
frightening and gross which kind of
makes sense in that world of like
grounded you know zodiac Killers the
first thing is like I think correct me
in the comics or correct me in the chat
if I'm wrong is uh is like one of the
more like legit serial killer like just
out there just to murder people doesn't
really have a ton of like agenda for
like I was wrong there's a boy it's just
like no I like to like kill people he
was a literal Professor that went insane
and now he kills people
um so at least he's earned his Professor
all right so yeah yeah he's not there uh
yeah uh teacher's assistant pig doesn't
roll out the tongue as well no no
Stoller stolen academic uh for him
Adjunct professor
okay
um uh and uh well and and so interesting
in that we know okay Todd Phillips and
Joaquin Phoenix right they're doing
Joker too a separate Universe from Matt
Reeves Batman stuff is there a
possibility somebody like a James Gunn
or something like that what if they
pitched their own Batman thing you think
DC would be like sure go for it we can
have multiple competing Batmans well I
mean I will say the Joker doesn't have a
Batman right like there he doesn't think
there's Thomas Wayne but there's not
like barely has a joke yeah barely has a
joker in it uh introduce me as the Joker
um so yeah I think if if they want to
make another Batman movie it's weird
because you had the like uh Suicide
Squad had a Batman in it for a kind of a
flashback sequence yeah and it wasn't
Ben Affleck right it was like no it was
it was it was him but he wasn't
necessarily like Justice League Batman
he was like a little different right
it's a little odd this is this is
Suicide Squad not the suicides right
this was the first original he was in a
scene with Will Smith right yeah and
with Harley Quinn and stuff
um so yeah I think they would let James
go do it but yeah do a movie about a
villain that we never even see Batman or
like we only see like tangentially
um we never seen without a mask on you
know it's not about Bruce Wayne at all
and this is like DC with Batman is
facing a similar issue to Sony with
Spider-Man right and that they have one
hero that is one of the most popular
movie kind of Heroes and franchises in
the world and what else can we do with
them besides make one Batman movie every
three years right so it's like are
people gonna go see a Crave in the
hunter movie are people gonna go see a
Clayface movie they that's what they
want they are of course we are they've
got four tickets sold right here green
lighted
um yeah uh and then other things in
development at DC right we know that um
oh you all right yeah my jaw fell out oh
no it went back out
king cobra
uh so we know that uh Patty Jenkins has
made a and I this is they use this term
in the article a scriptment combination
script and treatment for Wonder Woman
three
um it's expected she's expected to have
that finished
um that is still in development that
we're not hearing a lot of other news
about what a woman three about it going
into production or anything like that
but it's out there Patty Genesis is
pushing it Gail Gadot is playing uh like
the evil queen right in uh and like it's
snow white yeah I know you're talking
about I'm wondering she's a little busy
right now okay yeah but she can make
some room in her schedule that's her
signature role right speaking I thought
it was that imagine video
never try to put anything nice out into
the world okay you're just gonna get
[ __ ] on by the internet I would know uh
well I mean hey if if anybody knows
cringe and has mastered it and has
learned to live with it it is us here at
the break room
just wait till they get hit the
Redemption threshold yeah
you didn't know your cringe daddies were
here today over on the right side of the
table
um some other news
or cringe mommies or you guys are not
cringe you guys I wasn't saying you guys
weren't as cringy as me and Zach yeah I
thought you guys were soft boys we are
the soft boys but we're also the cringe
daddies soft boys become cringe daddies
and cringe daddies become ghosts
is it a hard time to make cringe daddies
and easy times to make soft softy boys
yeah I don't know
um so also this is interesting news
there's already and this is not a
scriptment but a full-blown script
written for the flash sequel oh the
movie that is not coming out until next
year has a full script written for a
sequel I think it's under the assumption
that when that movie is a hit they can
go quick into the next one oh yeah
because I mean despite all of the off
the court drama surrounding star Ezra
Miller by all accounts The Flash movie
is great like a lot of like early
reports and stuff like that are like
this is one of the best DC movies
they've made a long time you think that
zazlov on his burner accounts on Twitter
maybe seen the flash it's great let's
forgive them folks uh I actually heard
that the villain in the flash is testing
higher than any other DC movie okay I
heard that The Flash movie is going to
reset the hierarchy of power yeah in the
dce these are deep cuts for the for the
fans it's like a movie it's like a movie
like Harry Styles would say
um so again that movie's not coming out
until next summer June of 2012. and
that's like an interesting thing this
was in that same article right Chad's
killing it with some of the names
but I caught one on the corner I did
notice this news of like a flash sequel
this was in that same article that yeah
from this big report which makes you
wonder like is someone trying to get
that news out there like sure this would
be exist all right we have a script for
it yeah and if you are if you are Andy
machietti who's the director of that
film if you are anybody on Ezra Miller's
team right you not only want this movie
to be a success you want it to be a
franchise right and it makes sense that
the sequel exists because The Flash
movie was supposed to come out last year
right God I mean the the not to steal a
term but the scriptment for this movie
is probably three years old the sequel
yeah right because the script for the
flash was like eight years old yeah so
we won't see Aquaman 2 for a number
or Jason Momoa I know let his movie come
out
um but uh take that wig off stop stop
stop it made me laugh every time
um uh also and then he's been in the
news a lot Henry Cavill bless the star
is in the news a lot hey Witcher uh
blood origin which I don't think he's
gonna be in he's coming out in December
spin-off with The Witcher did you guys
see season two of The Witcher I gotta
watch that one I need to catch up yeah
hey toss a coin in A View to your
Witcher all right oh yeah you got a
little time when you finish and or are
you idiots you simps you watch and or
then you watch The Witcher and then you
call me yeah speaking of toss an
aquarium I think you know Chelsea row uh
my cat is cuter than yours uh Jeremy
Leah uh a lot of folks uh how close are
we to sing in one of these songs we
worked really hard on these the songs
are really good we're gonna work on them
we stole them oh that's right we stole
these we kissed someone somebody kissed
Bryce and I liked him hey so nice he
gives choice huh
um okay Harry couple's been in the news
a lot because you know there's some uh
rumors that Dwayne Johnson himself is
spreading that he's in Black Adam okay
uh and supposedly
um Man of Steel 2 is in the works
they're currently looking for writers
they want to bring it back as Superman
bring them in Jessica is available to
work uh do you have some thoughts on Man
of Steel too um I'm gonna kill him in
the First Act
and I know I know people are like
Jessica don't do that but I gotta and
then we're just gonna make it a movie
about someone else I'm gonna go the
ending of uh a book of boba fit and
bring in another character bringing
Wonder Woman to take over the last you
know what I'm talking about oh just make
it about sand people if you can't handle
that check out my film Snuffer man about
an 80 year old sex freak from Hoboken
New Jersey
you know what are they raising is it
organic is it just a purely wheat are
they a mixed there doing some crop
rotations maybe they get in some
sunflowers there for your nitrogen uh
depletion yeah beans one year corn the
next that's right
um okay hey these were free let me see
these are free if you made it this far
into the episode of DC uh you got these
I'm sure they did I'm sure someone at DC
watches every episode in combs for ideas
in among the writers that are supposed
to be being discussed uh for Man of
Steel Two Christopher Macquarie oh yeah
you don't recognize that name he's
basically done all of the Mission
Impossible movies for the last 10 years
with
um Tom Cruise he's it's almost his
full-time job I think he also had
something to do with top gun Maverick
um but Henry Cavill was in a
minute no they don't dude that was the
best one oh crazy he cocked his arm he
tucked his arm before he punched that's
when they fight in the bathroom yeah yes
you know that um Wong does that in
She-Hulk when he opens the portal and he
has the like Star Wars version of vibro
necklace and he goes and I was like oh I
was like Henry Chrissy redeemed a song
for us bless you oh crazy pushes over
the edge okay
um Tommy you want to break glass on uh
giving him a song uh This song is called
Black Canary and it's pretty serious
okay so please no uh no joke no smiling
okay
[Music]
black canary singing in the dead of
night
take these canceled wings and learn to
fly all your life
you were only waiting for your movie to
arrive
black canary singing in the dead of
night
take those teary eyes and wait and see
all your life
you'll be probably waiting for justice
league three or maybe only waiting for
Zack Snyder to be free or maybe only
waiting for a call from David Discovery
or maybe only waiting for direct to DVD
I made the movie you've got a good set
of pipes I will say I know that um that
was a stolen song again from DC head
starters uh but um that was loving again
every time we hit a different 100
dollars in Super Chat I heard Brandon
and Jessica do wedding earlier yeah it
would be worth it no you want to hear
this yeah okay Chrissy also put it in
her own song uh to the tune of piano man
called you the Tommy man oh I'm the
Tommy man baby
um
Tommy camps or Captain God forgot
stop him Brandon Brandon he has to be
stopped that's um from Splats the
musical okay
um so uh it's about cats with diarrhea
oh my God there's no jellicle choice
this year there's just Helly hole
choices
all cats must die no
um okay so uh again Dwayne Dwayne The
Rock Johnson's been landed slip that
Henry Cavill is going to appear in Black
Adam and Superman it's a mild spoiler uh
a little bummed that we got that would
have been really fun to see that in the
theater but he was just genuinely like
like he he like because I don't okay
maybe fight me on this do you think the
rock no or Dwayne Johnson sorry Dwayne
Johnson knows he's like as well
rehearsed on the red carpet as everyone
else is to not spoil yes
he's been into Jumanji films
and but like DC and Marvel they you know
they have people following them all the
time and being like you can't say this
stuff do you think he was genuine like
this is my movie I don't care they're
too afraid to tell him they're like
Dwayne yeah well you shouldn't say dude
I mean kind of on that note so the same
big article
um had a lot of great information about
how this came to be and basically the uh
Dwayne Johnson wanted Henry Cavill
Superman to show up in this movie the DC
Executives were like no we don't want
that and he went around them and went
straight to like the head the heads
above them and made it happen so it's
like Dwayne Johnson is a big enough
player this is definitely like his movie
he is the Kevin feige of Black Adam yeah
right like he is the main driving force
he's the reason this movie got made if
it's a success it will actually be
because of him and he's kind of calling
some of the political shots behind the
scenes let's be honest Zach what we're
kind of getting at here is it seems like
Pro Grapplers pro wrestlers if you will
have a bit of a Chokehold oh or maybe
have the DC EU in a Full Nelson and I'll
say if that sounds interesting to you
you might just like something we have
coming on later in the show oh Tommy's
that was a genuine leg message three T's
no balls
never play pickup basketball with a
bunch of guys with scissors for hands uh
also apparently the entire Cameo it was
like the movie was basically wrapped
um and and there's a furious round of
negotiations that happened around Labor
Day and the deadline and like the scene
was shot in mid-september it's
mid-october right now the movie's about
to come come out oh my god do you think
they rushed it they did you think
cavill's got a full beard Maybe cover it
up with CJ I made that joke on the
pre-call that would be amazing if I was
in your Henry Cavill should just be
growing stunt facial hair at this point
right just to ruin potential Superman
appearances she's like if I don't want
to do it I just I grow my hair out that
way I get to the side because they're
never going to make that mistake again
and have his weird robot mouth lower
half that most uncomfortable CGI ever
um when are we seeing Black Adam are we
seeing that are you trying to see that
Thursday night and talk about on the
show Friday are we gonna try to see it
over the weekend and talk about it on
Monday uh you know seriously it works
better for me but I could you know I
could be talking at any time
I know we got some folks watching from
Europe and and other places that you
know maybe there's a different release
schedule but like hey when are you gonna
see this movie if we do talk about it on
Friday after seeing it
yeah we'll do maybe a spoiler segment
but we won't ruin it with a thumbnail or
anything like that and we'll definitely
get into it deep next Monday because
we're all gonna be excited about this
film and want to talk about the
hierarchy of the dcau is about to be
totally that could be making another
shirt for Black Adam if he goes in
season on Thursday oh that's right hey
if if there's a a Groundswell in Burbank
California to go meet us
um
uh probably don't want that
but we're near Burbank but if there is
Buffalo Wild Wings near the theater so
you know maybe we all go get some wings
a little Wild Wings meet up uh throw it
in the chat if you're if you're in the
Burbank area garlic parm Wings in the
chat guys dipped in Buffalo sauce then
blue cheese and I call it the Holy
Trinity the threesome your mother didn't
tell you okay are those things both
sounded good
oh and then just finally before we move
on from DC news right so all the things
that have been kind of um uh greenlit
and canceled Etc uh JJ Abrams Mega
producer director JJ Abrams has an
overall deal with Warner Brothers and
he's been developing projects for DC for
years none of them have been greenlit or
made at this point right there was he
was the driving force one of the driving
forces behind the kind of black Superman
movie that was being talked about based
on a ton of AC Coates is um comic series
I think was Michael B Jordan attached to
that at some point that was that a
separate black Superman uh project
um but maybe now if they're moving
forward with Man of Steel Two that might
not happen yeah and I think you know I
think that movie maybe depends on this
Flash movie too right if they're getting
into the idea of the Multiverse they I
yeah they're so desperate to get this
Flash movie out but they're not
finding a way to do it I don't know
they're in a tough they're in a tough
spot so I wanna I wanna dive into this
JJ Abrams overall deal if if we're just
general questions for maybe the chat
ends with you guys because I have been
fascinated about this deal since it was
signed because it was essentially signed
shortly after I think the force awakens
right like it was because it included a
cause for him to continue finishing that
the Star Wars franchise which is
obviously Disney projects what JJ Abrams
projects have come out through Wonder
has anything come out probably yeah what
Westworld oh so TV yes
Lovecraft country so he's producing
stuff I think was he even um was he the
Watchman series who has lindoff oh okay
there's a fellow he might have been a
producer on that actually yeah but
you're right no big tent poles and
non-franchises and now I mean this one
might also be a part and they threw the
bank at him right he's making a lot of
money
um it's maybe one reason Star Trek films
are not getting made because that's a
Paramount a different studio and his his
bread and butter is is here at Warner
Brothers Discovery
um yeah it's a great question now maybe
we'll eat our words and he'll have five
movies in the next five years that are
all huge and I hope that's a great guy I
didn't mean that as an attack on JJ I'm
just curious because I remember like you
know these Mega deals started coming out
as the streamers really took off except
McFarland famously I think got like 900
million dollars the South Park guys got
900 mil it's like all these insane
overall deals with these the screamer
Studios and then of course Warner
Brothers which is their own studio
studio and I just I I wonder there's
really no way to quantify with streaming
now with the content that's coming out
and JJ Abrams is such a specific person
to kind of go off of the grid directing
uh big features so I don't know it's
just curious to me I'm just having a
discussion with my Bros and hosts on the
on the break
okay
you're my bro oh which one's the house
I'm clearly the hoe here
oh Brandon oh wow okay mj2997 and
Chrissy uh they deserve to hear some
more music also they're throwing their
own lyrics mj2997 Don't Stop Me Now I'm
having such a good time don't stop me
now's axing us another Gary Oldman song
yes
even even better than that Brandon
Jessica do we have another song stolen
from the DC Library I think should we do
this one we can try okay I can't hit it
okay this this movie is still scheduled
to come out oh good uh we'll see we'll
see uh but uh this this is to the tune
of you lead and I follow okay because I
kind of okay this is about a uh you know
a more dark side of the the DC EU okay
[Music]
demons they are possessing the people is
there no one to fight them as they crawl
up from out
on my bookshelf a DVD is collecting some
dust it's a
franchise
That Never Was wait Constantine
for another quick smoke do you remember
the movie we made two decades ago this
is the
sequel
please watch it wow wow wow or should I
say yeah
for my single song
and everywhere I go I look for milk get
in the pot okay
oh
again
um
oh somebody did put Constantine because
they clear yeah porn parody Same Team
not too much
um okay uh and again we're we're already
thank you to the generosity of Chris the
MJ 297 Benny knock and a couple other
folks uh we're already on our way to a
third uh Redemption well we've got a
couple more events still a couple more
songs
we appreciate everybody in in both the
super chats and in the chat uh and then
real quick that kind of wraps up the DC
news and there was a lot we look forward
to more of that coming out and again we
want to see some of these DC movies we
want Warner Brothers to get their s
together so that uh we can watch stuff
together I love that I'm fine saying
comes into you but then I uh paraphrase
you said s yeah uh we do have some some
Marvel news too and it's all about our
boy Charlie Cox uh our favorite Irish
actor who does a pretty capacity I know
I know I know the important parody is
right there yep
um uh what would Daredevil what would
the series
[Music]
he's like naked
yes there it is
you're gonna love seeing his Cane uh
no no Brandon we are all civilized a lot
and we act like it on the show there's a
lot of evidence to the contract
um okay so he's he has a couple big
profiles out in Daredevil the Seaman in
Hell's Kitchen
that sounds like a musical and I'm here
for it
stop it stop it
Beauty and the Queen
I was trying to think of something for
Spider-Man turn out tonight
turn off the dark oh okay we'll come
back to it
um but anyways uh it's got a couple big
profiles which does he have another
project out right now is that what he's
just or is it just built around his
She-Hulk appearance because he's doing
he's supposed to She-Hulk his own series
and then yeah right so I don't know if
he's in another movie she's just like
he's in the Zeitgeist a lot right now so
he's got these two big profiles and he
talked a lot about I guess the original
plan for him coming into the MCU
formally was it was originally just
going to be that little Cameo and no way
home and then maybe a couple cameos and
She-Hulk he didn't know that he was
getting his own series uh
um born again until a couple days before
Comic-Con wow exciting stuff isn't that
wild everyone all right back then
producer John's still pretty choked up
about uh
um okay uh but I mean he had a lot of
great uh quotes right like
um uh talking about like only finding
out a few days before Comic-Con which I
love like again when Kevin feige calls
you he's like clear your schedule and
you're like okay
coming right now is Bryce working
shout out shout out to Bryce in the chat
um but one thing I like kind of because
we don't know right like the Netflix
series Daredevil Punisher Jessica Jones
um Iron Fist all the defender stuff
right had its own Vibe it had its own
level of uh kind of mature content a lot
of gritty violence in those some
sexuality we haven't necessarily seen
him in MCU uh product until kind of
She-Hulk um and so we haven't really
known what's Disney plus Daredevil gonna
look like and he kind of pointed out
something I think is really interesting
we wouldn't have guessed it doesn't
really cover like how gritty it will be
but it seems like they're gonna have a
much better budget and they'll have more
CGI and he talked about they'll be able
to do more comic book esque violence
like you talked about like in the
Netflix series they could never do a
scene where he bounces the Baton like
off the wall to like hit somebody in my
head because like yeah it was almost all
practical in that series but he's like
it's just literally physically
impossible to do something like that or
you would hurt somebody but now they can
do that with CGI because we know so for
some of these Marvel shows I assume all
of them they're spending at least a
million dollars on an episode at least
one division was like pretty expensive a
lot of fully CGI characters in Moon
Knight yeah I mean and she'll you know
you have a character who is digital
every episode like a full digital
mapping character sometimes you have
Abomination Hulk and She-Hulk in the
same scene and it's like that's
expensive stuff yes as k-e-b-i-n pointed
out hey yo
um and it kind of went on to hint that
like him and she hoax uh interactions
may not be done we said there's a lot
more fun to be had there whoa so I mean
is it guaranteed She-Hulk shows up in
Daredevil born again I want to see them
both in Oklahoma hanging out with that
girl yeah
I kind of love the idea too and this is
like the bigger picture there's always
been comedy in the MCU but geook was
like the first comedic show yes and that
length that changed how everything
happens in the world and I like the idea
that the MCU affected by the lens
through which we view it in a weird way
like if she Hulk shows up in an Avengers
movie right she's not able to break the
fourth wall because the lens of that
movie doesn't give her that ability
because it's not comedic or something
like that I know it's very interesting
to see because Charlie Cox has also been
saying like they're still not very clear
if it's the same Daredevil it's a
different Daredevil but he did point out
like the Netflix show was gritty so that
Daredevil was gritty and like seeing him
be more comedic and She-Hulk is
interesting where it's like yeah it's
not super serious it's just like the
lens we view that character through
affects how they yeah which is
interesting and maybe even if Daredevil
shows up an echo he might be a little
different in Echo than he wasn't
She-Hulk and he might be a little
different in Echo than he will be in
dear never born again really sad if we
don't see She Hulk and Echo with him
I just talked to Jane the other day you
know well Thor would always be like oh
yeah Jane's not here right now or
something is he gonna have a line where
he yeah he talks to her on the phone or
something like FaceTime or can we see a
Tatiana maslani not hulked out oh that's
that's Matt Murdoch with just his
glasses in his case in Oklahoma
I don't know will be interesting if
you're set in Oklahoma this is more of
kind of a globe spanning maybe there's
some flashbacks maybe there's some jump
cut something like that well you know
when it comes to She-Hulk being in
Oklahoma she can't say no well oh
um if you want us to do oklahoma-based
parody songs
um I guess throw that in the chat or
check out my porn parody musical chokio
Mama
what is that is that excuse me
no no not just a little no no no so she
can hit a climax that she's ever had oh
no okay well you guys forget it could
have been forget two seconds of Silence
before we get into our sponsors for the
day hey do you ever find yourself and
this happens to me mindlessly scrolling
through your favorite streaming app
trying to find something to watch you
have all these programs at your
fingertips and you don't know what to
watch
do you miss the good old days when you
could just turn on the TV and something
was already playing that's the best part
about staying in a hotel I think you go
and you turn on the TV there's something
playing already I don't have to decide
on anything well folks Pluto TV has
on-demand and linear channels curated by
real people who select the movies and
channels you love some of your favorite
binge-worthy shows and movies have their
own channels that you can watch 24 7.
include they have like a walking judge
channel that just shows The Walking Dead
they have an MTV The Challenge Channel
that's just episodes of The Challenge
even Adam's Family Channel
24 hours ago they have like theme
channels like horror and thrillers and
action 90s action is it creepy and kooky
it's creepy and koopy it's mysterious
and spooky folks uh I like their old
movie channels they I watched I had no
idea there's a movie called Robin and
Marion that's about it's Sean Connery
and I've seen that movie yeah yeah uh
and Audrey Hepburn as like old Robin and
married who have broken up yeah they're
trying to like rekindle their romance
it's wild stuff uh it's great Pluto TV
is awesome and the best part it's
entirely free totally free so check it
out for yourself at pluto.tv you can
watch on your computer your phone your
TV at home probably has the app built
into it yeah do it check it out TV
thousands of channels it's really
something for everybody and we're
sponsoring the show all week long you're
also sponsoring our house the dragon
breakdowns this week it's Pluto TV week
here at new rockstar thank you Pluto TV
two seconds of Silence 2001 1002. uh the
guy who said blue Oklahoma in the chat
you're the hero but let's not forget
stroke your Bona uh
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's true
uh sorry
uh well no uh I think Tommy it's a
certain time in the show oh yeah sorry
for mandatory puns
yes mandatory fun the segment's so horny
we play the graphic till it's corny hit
my graphic again
oh yes the segment that's so hot we play
the graphic a lot hit by traffic again
yes
the segment's so oh I'm sorry there's a
guy
Romeo Juliet is good and like just a
Rhymes
now do You Hear the People cream
unbelievable you guys are desecrating a
sacred too mandatory in the show where I
invite my three I'm screaming best
friends in the whole world to do some
fun with me now for you simps in the
chat take your headphones out of your
ears this is gonna be wrestling theme
it's gonna get loud I know you just want
us to read your chat R.I.P my headphones
so you can feel like you're noticed by
four internet big Ballers we're sick of
you roll over in your dumpsters hold
your hands over your ears so there's no
Echo your trash now now that I've said
my peace thank you for watching
Wayne Johnson and John Cena as we said
before they're steaming
so many projects are in limbo but Black
Adam and Peacemaker they're sitting
pretty baby they ain't going anywhere so
I thought we could embody our favorite
wrestlers now we spent all our costume
Budget on Friday's costumes so we're not
going to necessarily look like these
wrestlers but we will be trying to sound
like them and we'll show you a picture
of the wrestler we're talking about and
we're gonna pitch ourselves for DC EU
projects by cutting good old-fashioned
wrestling promos now Brandon I think you
had One queued up yeah yeah will you
scroll up give me the mic give me an
effort Mike oh my god listen up Jazz lab
I know you've already had this character
portrayed many times in DC movies I'm
going a little macho man
but you've never had this man play by
the game the cerebral assassin Hunter
Hearst Helmsley Triple H it's time to
tag me into the dceu and finally have
the Lex Luthor that can bring the
sledgehammer down on Superman and let
this bald-headed Dynamo show you what
it's like to have a Lex Luthor that can
take on the Man of Steel surrounded by a
20-foot tall steel cage and a No Holds
Barred Hell in a Cell match I will
pedigree Carl L straight to call hell
and if you're not down with that I got
two words for you
I did it I was just not happy with the
whale
don't be afraid it's your old pale
mankind
just like Bruce Wayne I only truly feel
like myself when I'm behind a mask so
please Mr McMahon I mean Mr zazlop
please let me be Batman I promise I
won't hurt anyone more than I've been
hurt before which is a lot to be fair I
know exactly how to make this movie a
hit I'll face off against the Riddler
what's that
I already faced The Riddler well hang on
I've got a little friend I want you to
meet oh no
this is the Riddler
he's coming for you and what's better
than one Riddler
do Riddlers
again the mic is not right no my flag
the mic's very important
two Riddlers I call this one Paul Dano
and I call this one Jim Carrey so what
do you say Mr Z how about we cover
Gotham City and thumbtacks and see who
comes out on top have a nice day oh wow
oh okay Jessica I can take mine
you didn't like me when I was nice you
don't like me now what I mean oh the
bloodline
hey Roman cionis uh the black mask and I
deserve it I deserve it because
everything here belongs to me this
camera number two belongs to me go to
camera four ah oh
my camera three
go back to camera four go back to camera
four John John in the back the producer
switching belongs to me this this life
belongs to me this is all mine this is
me and my family deserves it and I
deserve it could be at the top yeah
because I'm fine as hell oh yeah
and then uh mine is uh you know imagine
the lights are dimming okay imagine I'm
coming out
he's got the whole world
hey hey it's me Bray Wyatt I want to
play Lobo Intergalactic Bounty Hunter
yeah you know what sometimes they cast
pretty upstanding actors to play
degenerates right you guess you you make
a Tom Hardy or a Chris Evans look gross
I already look gross oh okay
unbelievable is a guy who rides a
motorcycle through the cosmos yeah okay
so let me be your Lobo oh I like that
oh that was riveting I gotta say maybe
one of my favorite mandatory funds of
all time that's I guess that's it right
that's all okay that's a wrap okay whoa
whose music
it's me Daddy magic Daddy
and I am interviewing I mean auditioning
whatever you call it for the role of
king shark I just want you to know get
this camera on my face
I just want you to know that I missed my
son's first steps to be here
oh my God what a grandfather is Daddy
tragic Now give me the wrong give me the
role of king shark I'm gonna eat Jason
Momoa I'm gonna eat him I'm gonna show
him all over my mouth
sorry folks we don't know why that
Interruption happened oh oh my daddy
message just came on the show
surprised I am hurt damn daddy magic she
doesn't work here surprise running from
Whitney I got it wow well I'd run a poll
but I think all five of us just did a
wonderful job our thanks to Whitney for
for coming on the show I didn't even
know she's gonna do that wow that's why
wrestling is so wonderful you know you
never know who's gonna show up how uh
John how much money have we raised
256 well I'm not going to give these
away for free well here let me real
quick shout out some of the folks that
have been the super chat today we
appreciate all of you Brad Van uh loving
that mankind impression Dave bloom or
blonde I apologize booty beads they said
we all laughed until we're dead they
laid Us in the coffin made of wood wood
uh Chelsea Rowe say nailed it I assume
that was for the song Maybe yeah maybe
although people were loving Jess's Roman
absolutely acknowledge Jesse knowledge
the tribal Chief Alice 2746 thank you
Chrissy Chrissy thrown in a couple okay
we appreciate we love you crazy uh
throws another gold gold bar ancient
Egyptian word of the day I can't
pronounce pronounce
it means Stranglehold which is what Jess
wants to do to Tommy something
I believe it's pronounced
[Laughter]
how would Al Pacino pronounce it
[Laughter]
she's got a big ass you're all up in it
okay uh and thank you to every Max Lee
thrown in a super chat right there
um you know what oh cancel
it's been such a fun show I feel like we
should break them off they're close
enough all right you got something
cooking I'll grab one more song that we
stole after Bryce and I had our moment
and it was it was a moment uh this is a
song that's kind of interesting because
it's an end credit song but it's about
the actor who played the character oh
okay so you got to think about the
character but the song is about the
actor so let me just explain this one
more time there's a song okay it's about
the actor okay who played the character
I'm lost but I think I'll catch up may I
have my microphone please oh okay
oh no it's for me because I'm the Talent
singing the song sorry I apologize
you may play with my socks
why are they so crunchy uh let's just
say I solved a few riddles of my own
Thomas
how hard is it to make me come all right
now yeah here's the song
they're just a Speedster with desires
as a farm in the Northeast they know the
terrorize of Hawaii Feast they're
running fast and never tired I love this
had to replace the dad sketching flat
conflicts aren't as acting's bad
oh they've got both feet on the ground
well they're burning it down
oh
they still have real big goals but on
lots of pistols this flash is not fired
[Applause]
they maybe should have been fired
Grant Gustin is not higher
oh they've got both feet on the ground
well they're burning it down this flesh
is not fire
yes and great 100 consistent use of
proper pronouns in that
[Music]
um
now and then